historian Jill Lepore has written books
on topics ranging from Wonder Woman to
the Tea Party the best-selling author is
now taking on a much bigger topic the
entire history of the United States her
new book is called these truths
Lepore tracks the nation's story
starting with Christopher Columbus's
voyage to the Civil War the civil rights
era and president Trump's election in
2016 and she is with us now morning
welcome good morning this is kind of an
epic job you took on but it seems to me
it's we couldn't need it more than we
need it now and and one of the things I
was struck by just in looking at this
book is that a lot of us believe we're
living in very polarized times but but
this book shows us in fact that's been
going on for a long time it has been
going on for a long time that doesn't
really must have the obligation to think
about why we're stuck in this now and
get ourselves out of it I mean I too
felt like we really wanted there to be a
book like this so I thought oh I guess
I'll have to it's understandable the
day-to-day news is completely consuming
and we have it's covered in such
incredible detail but it's worth pulling
back into trying to look across the
centuries at the origins of these
patterns and how people got out of
similar jams in the past so that's one
of the reasons I wanted to try to cover
the whole sweep of American history and
all its contradictions and the
complexities this would be like the
partisanship and the inability to get
along in Congress I mean they were
caning and beating each other in the
1800s they were and of course you know
we we fought a war a civil war in which
750,000 people died but it was a war of
emancipation and to be celebrated as
well I think what's different about our
contemporary moment of polarization is
that the polarization we were
experiencing now was very particularly
built by political consultants in the
1970s 1980s really trying to get people
out to vote over these emotional issues
guns and abortion and that was sort of
that was the work that was done by
political consultants for a short term
let's win this election next week yeah
you said they said the difference is
essentially automation now they now
write it so that it was done by hand
this was built manually but in but after
the opening of the Internet in the late
1990s and especially after the rise of
social media that polarization really is
now done by automation
so it's very difficult to figure out I
think so many people have great goodwill
would like the country to be less
polarized would like to have
conversations across partisan divisions
yes even some of the more nefarious of
our elected officials I would like to
think they would like to get us past
this I did this week so it's very
difficult to do in the because of the
way the internet was opened up and if
wholly unregulated you highlight the
female voices that are missing from our
history books why so important to
include them and sort of that story yeah
I mean shocking if you shocked to hear
you know women's historians have been
writing incredible work for the last
half century we're covering the lives
and voices of women and Simmel hasn't
made it into the big story that we tell
about politics is if there's sort of
women's history and then there's
political history so I really wanted to
I didn't want have a segregated history
I wanted to integrate those stories and
if you don't pay attention to women in
the history of American politics what
you miss is a really crucial part of our
political style which is the female
crusade the moral crusade because women
were denied the vote for so long that
the way that they acted politically was
to crusade as it came out of the Second
Great Awakening out of the evangelical
revival of the 1830s they brought that
evangelical fervor to the abolitionist
movement and slavery a moral crusade
that they wanted that women and men won
they brought it to the women's rights
movement in the 20th century though they
also brought it to Phyllis Schlafly as
campaign against the ER a was a moral
crusade you it's actually in the 20
century been often a conservative you
were working on the the chapter on the
Civil War when President Trump was
elected because you said that you would
plan to end with the inauguration of
Barack Obama but in the middle of that
you said I need to change the ending I
need to change them yeah it was really
tough because the inauguration of brocco
run was it's dramatic it's a great
ending you know whatever whoever you
voted for just tada like this was look
sort of something is solved about the
American agony of racial bondage and
discrimination segregation there or it
seems to be solved at that moment it's
also a little distant in the past we
have some Vantage on that election but
when the election happened in 2016 it
just seemed to me a dereliction of duty
to not cover that election people who
came out to vote for Trump supported him
felt themselves to be part of a
political revolution
it's also clearly realigning revolutions
yeah I think we learn to say truth
matters still do yeah truth matters and
your book we're absolutely laid out very
Bo absolutely matters and it's a
struggle
yeah allegorical thank thank you so much
thank you these truths is on sale now